Wo sind wir heute in der Notaufnahme oder im Praxis?
Wo ich bin oder wo Sie sind oder wo wir heute...
Unsere Schauspielerinnen.
Unsere Schauspieler sind in der Notaufnahme.
Notaufnahme.
Ja, das war es sich.
Ja, jetzt können wir anfangen.
Ja, gerne.
Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kapagann.
Ich bin hier als zuständiger Assistenzerstin, Tätig.
Mit Ihnen würde ich gerne das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir über Ihre Akterin beswerben,
möchte ich ein paar Allgemeine fragstellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Martin Bauer.
Martin ist der Vorname, Bauer der Nachname.
Herr Bauer, kann ich Richtige aussprachen?
Ja, Bauer ist richtig, ja.
Herr Bauer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 20. August 1961.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Oh, viel. 85 kg.
85 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,76 m.
Eigentlich nicht so viel.
Herr Bauer, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit einigen Stunden starke Schmerzen in der Brust.
Seit einer Stunde?
Seit einigen Stunden.
Seit dem Frühstück.
Seit drei Stunden.
Seit einer Stunde.
Seit einem Frühstück.
Seit drei Stunden.
Sie sind plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja.
Manchmal werden Sie etwas stärker.
Aber mir in Krankenhäuser
haben Sie ein Spray gegeben?
Ja.
Ich bin ja mit dem Krankenwagen gekommen.
Da hat mir ein Sanitäter so einen Spray gegeben.
Danach war es etwas besser.
Okay.
Sie sind aufgetreten?
Ja.
Es ist mehr so ein drückender Schmerz.
Wie wenn jemand die Brust drückt.
Herr Bauer,
ich messe Ihre Oxigen
oder die Zutaten.
So schnell wie möglich
Ihre
Elektro-Kardiografie
schreiben.
Gleichzeitig
stelle ich meine Fragen.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
nachdem Frühstück tritt
Ihre Schmerzen auf.
Heute?
Das war ja bisher einmalig.
Ja, das war früher.
Sie haben früher nicht ähnliche Beschwärter.
Ja, vielleicht mal vor drei Wochen.
Da habe ich beim Nachbarn geholfen,
einen Loch zu graben im Garten mit der Schaufel.
Da war es auch etwas enge über der Brust.
Aber nicht so schlimm wie heute.
Wo sind Ihr Schmerz?
Hier im Brustkorb.
Das geht ein bisschen hier oben in den Hals hoch.
Ja.
Ihre Schmerzen strahlen in den Hals.
Ein bisschen nach oben.
Nach oben.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen, Sie haben gesagt,
nachdem
Oxigen
ist der Schmerz leichter.
Der Sanitäter hat mir einen Spray gegeben.
Ein Spray.
Hat er unter die Zunge gesprüht.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerz-Kolophon 1 bis 10.
Wenn 1 ist leichter und 10, ist der stark geschmerzen.
Können Sie mir...
8.
Was denken Sie?
Was könnte eine bestimmte Ursache für Ihre Schmerzen auftreten?
Können Sie sagen?
Heute war es so beim Frühstück.
Vor 3 Wochen habe ich...
Ein bisschen belastet.
Verarbeitet.
Okay, vielleicht dann.
Waren Sie vor 3 Wochen beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, das ging danach auch wieder weg.
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
ich war danach deswegen nicht beim Arzt.
Haben Sie wegen der Schmerz
eine Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden verbunden mit dem Atmen?
Aufatmen und einatmen, wachsen das nicht?
Haben Sie dort brennen?
Nein, habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich vertrage vom Essen her, kann ich alles essen.
Mein Arzt sagt nur, ich esse zu viel, deswegen bin ich zu schwer.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Bleiben Sie an bestimmten chronischen Erkrankungen,
wie z.B. Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder Herzkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 10 Jahren, 12 Jahren,
einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Welche Medikamente?
Auf dem Zettel habe ich hier das Stehen.
Kann die werden?
8 Milliarden.
Besuchen Sie bei Hausarzt oder Herzarzt?
Kardiologie regelmäßig?
Ich gehe regelmäßig zum Hausarzt wegen meinem Zucker.
Regentzucker.
Haben Sie auch Blutzucker, Krankheit?
Ja.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie das?
Ja, auch seit knapp 10 Jahren, 8 Jahre, 9 Jahre.
Nehmen Sie wegen Blutzucker Medikamente ein?
Ja, das steht ja mit Formin.
800 Milligramm.
850.
Morgen eine halbe und abends eine.
Morgen eine halbe und abends eine ganze.
Dann nehme ich noch etwas ein gegen hohes Cholesterin.
Das heißt, das ist auch ein schwieriges Wort.
Das heißt, Rosovastatin.
5 Milligramm.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Ja, aber das ist schon ganz lange her.
Als Kind hatte ich eine blinde Operation.
Und eine Knieoperation, Meniscus.
Das war damals ein rechten Knie vom Fußballspielen.
Aber die Operation war erst vor 10 Jahren.
10 Jahre.
Haben Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Allergie?
Ja.
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Sind Sie gegen Corona vollständiger geimpft?
Ja, ich habe 3 Impfungen.
Erst vor 6 Wochen habe ich eine, wie heißt die, Booster-Impfung.
Booster-Impfung, genau.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Fibar?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schuttefrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, habe ich auch.
Ich fühle mich sonst eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Bis auf jetzt.
Morgen.
Wussten Sie?
Obwohl ich rauche ja.
Manchmal wusste ich schon etwas, aber nicht so schlimm.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich heiß rasen und heiß klopfen?
Nein.
Mit deinem Schmerz?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, immer ein bisschen zugenommen.
Aber das hängt am Essen.
Ich bewege mich nicht so viel.
Ich habe ja auch noch ein paar von Beruf.
Ja.
Wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie in letzten Monaten zugenommen?
Nein, im letzten Monat kann ich das jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich würde sagen, innerhalb von einem Jahr vielleicht 2 Kilo.
Okay, verstehe ich nicht.
Trinken Sie genug Wasser?
Wasser?
Nein, ich bin immer mit.
Wenn ich Bus fahre, nehme ich mir eine große Flasche Wasser mit.
Wenn es draußen noch wärmer ist, nehme ich vielleicht noch mehr mit.
Aber die trinke ich dann am Tag in den Laufe eines Tages aus.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Besonders in der letzten Zeit?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Ich kann gut schlafen.
Haben Sie Bemerk in Ihrer Sturl-Ferbung bemerkt?
Was ist eine Verferbung?
Haben Sie im Sturl Blut bemerkt?
Nein.
Nein, das ist in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Durchfall oder Teistopfung?
Nein, ich habe vor 3 Jahren eine Darm-Spiegelung machen lassen.
Eine Vorsorgendarm-Spiegelung.
Und das war alles gut.
Herr Bauer, ich möchte für Sie und mich zusammenfassen.
Sie haben heute Morgen und ungefähr vor 3 Stunden aufgetretene und dürrückende Brustschmerzen.
Sie haben die Brust von der Brust von der Brust aufgetreten.
Sie haben vor 3 Wochen eine schwierige Arbeit gemacht.
Sie haben Bluthochdruck und erhöhte Blutfettstöße.
Sie haben auch Zuckerkrankheit.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig 3 Medikamente ein.
Sie haben Kandarverstätten, Metformin und Röseverstätten.
Sie haben kein Fieber.
Sie haben gesagt, ich bin Raucher.
Wie viel Päckchen rauchen Sie täglich?
40 Jahre.
Sie haben 40 Jahre gebraucht.
Sie haben 20 Sigerätten.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sie haben nur 1,5 Liter.
Diese Frage ist nicht persönlich.
Sie haben ein Alkohol?
Sie leben in einer Eltern.
Sie haben eine Schwester.
Sie haben ein Blutdruck.
Sie sind 32 Jahre alt.
Sie haben eine Schwester.
Sie haben eine ÖKG.
Sie haben eine Sauerstoff-Sättinge.
Sie haben eine Maske.
Sie haben eine ÖKG.
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie haben eine Maske.
Die Vitalparameter sind gut.
Für meine Begriffe gehört der Patient stationär aufgenommen.
Wir schauen, ob wir auch eine Corona-Angiografie machen.
Es gibt noch ein günstiges Zeitfenster.
Was können wir in der Notaufnahme für die Infarktion?
Wir haben eine Nitrospray.
Man könnte es noch einmal mit Nitrospray geben.
Man kann es auch mit der Dosierung vorsichtig sein.
Man kann es auch mit Nitrospray geben.
Sie haben in der Notaufnahme SBO2-Messung gemacht.
Man hat auch etwas geschieht.
Das rauchen, übergewicht, Zucker, die familiäre Vorgeschichte.
Der Patient ist gut versorgt.
Sie haben es ruhig und gut gemacht.
Manchmal ist es besser.
Ich habe zuerst gedacht, Sie vergessen die Risikofaktoren.
Man kann die Satin nicht als 10mg Tablette, sondern nur als 8mg.
Sie haben mich nicht gefragt, nach der Dosierung.
Haben Sie bald Prüfung?
Ich werde am 5.2.Jahr in Deutschland abheben.
Ich wohne im Hessen.
April wird meine Prüfungstermine bekommen.
Ich habe zwei Prüfungen.
Ich möchte mich beim Schläß-Württemberg bewerben.
Deswegen brauche ich Telk-FSP.
Auf jeden Fall möchte ich im hessischen Arzt-Kammer-Püfung.
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Wir können das jetzt beenden.
Wir können es auch auf Dienstag machen.
Vielen Dank.
Tschüss.